hello thanks for the introduction as
well said I'm working on my master
thesis now and this is basically as a
site product of it
so my master thesis has to do with new
networks and I was kind of fighting with
them so I was trying to to learn on
actual data and I was also asking my
quote I was asking myself the question
it's just the data is it broken or do it
- something wrong so that's basically
the history of this and this is some
method I found and I would like to give
you an introduction now to dismiss it so
I will first talk a bit about neural
networks how its training work actually
because I don't assume that every one of
you is doing this all day and then we
will come to this automatic learners
after that or like these automatic
learners will be showed as in in sense
of two examples is because this is a
Python conference right so I found a
nice Python libraries to do this and
actually some code right so first how
does training a neural network work um I
think I assume a lot of you have seen is
this here is this famous
new network a very basic ones already
existed 20 years ago or even longer and
also this data set which is here
exemplified us mmm nest digital digital
recognition data set and the data comes
in and some prediction comes out so we
have this 10 10 fold output where each
of the predictions become it gets some
kind of predicted value so this is the
highest so this is the most probable one
for in an example of one data point for
example and when you train this the no
network algorithm is basically iterating
over the whole data and adapting weights
that are in between those neurons and
then you can lock some kind of loss and
ideally you lost
down because it's getting better and
also you want to have it convert so that
you like know when you're finished so I
drew in a little loop here so you have
this model lets you data comes in into
the loop but it does not really change
you have your model also called the
scoring function then you compute the
loss function on your card current
scoring function and then you change
your scoring function by some gradient
descent algorithm so you adapt your
model and the hard thing here is now to
get this picture so this is also like
now it's reversed because it's not lost
its the ecers see now so this is a nice
iteration where the accuracy converges
towards some like around 95 or it's a
bit over fittings or the training data
here you see is kind of getting to like
better than the validation so I could
have stopped here but it's a nicer one
and when it does not work then it looks
like this so when when some thing you do
is not like how it's supposed to be then
then here here in this case it was I
think some regularization issue so the
weights that I learned they kind of
exploded and then the no network could
not learn anything it went away and the
the thing was a binary decision so now
we are not really better than a coin
toss in this case and this actually
happens like often times so how to do
this systematically this in a loop is
something you can influence I forgot
this picture it's when you look at too
long at lost functions and something
this is happening so there's even the
whole block about lost functions by a
famous neural network research and like
a party it's collecting these nice
pictures
so how to influence this inner loop it's
by means of hyperparameters I already
said something that something with the
regularization went wrong
this happens into these two points in
these two points you can either
influence your your gradient your search
the learning rate for example would be
something to adapt or you can introduce
some decay or you can change your model
even the architecture would be something
that is a hyper parameter so the number
of neurons that is depicted here in the
middle in the hidden layer it's flexible
the output is fixed and the input is
also fixed but in the middle you can
change you can maybe put more neurons or
less the question is what is the right
number of neurons no one knows you have
to try
so this stem kind of included in an
outer loop just trying so now here's
this small loop we have seen before and
the loss function generated and when
when it converged and we can extract
from one like finished process we can
extract the best value so it would be
for example this here and store it into
our set of experiments so here what's
the last experiment then it has like
kind of I mean the number stop this just
an illustration don't look at the
numbers but the thing is now we know
this was our currently best set of hyper
parameters which we want to try so as a
researcher or as like machine Lana data
scientist you have to adapt a parameters
you can do this by different means the
most like the most stupid or the most
simple one is the gret grid search where
you just list your parameters and you
try everything but the thing is that it
explodes a lot really large really
really fast so I mean what I didn't
and so far training such a network can
take like for example up to a couple of
days or even weeks if they if you have a
lot of data then the iteration is like
very expensive computation so one
experiment is really expensive this is a
key key thing to mention here because
for like support vector machine or
something when when the data is like not
too large and it can just compute a
value but here you have to run and run
and run and then you see ok it converges
so when you try crit search then it
taste takes too long you cannot like
when you have a couple of hyper
parameters then you can get off it can
get to most millions of combinations
then another approach which is really
famous is random search
so you basically just be lucky so you
you run these experiments that maybe for
example when you don't have so much data
takes an hour then you can run 20 a day
and you just let it run for a couple of
days and see them what what was the best
so far very famous also grad student
search this is basically what I am doing
so I'm the poor Mouse a student who has
to tune these networks by any means I
mean I I'm not saying that these that
these combinations are really separate
so you can combine them this would be
the more like human approach and then
because this is so difficult most people
don't really do it anymore they appear
to expert that means you can like go to
the to some famous new network libraries
and download finished models it's
basically take off the shelf and use
them because they are already trained
and
the issues that I explained are not
existing so much anymore because they
already converged and you can the
assumption here is that your data is
similar to the data they trained it with
you can reuse them it's a very famous
approach in I guess if you are dealing
with neural networks you have done this
yeah what I wanted to mention here is
just a connection to tomorrow's to two
of tomorrow's talk but some library that
is similar to the one that blue yonder I
just explained its pison parameter
exploration tool kids just want to
advertise tomorrow's talk by all by my
eyes a cool library which are also
introduced here in this grad student
search so the consequence of all this is
now we would like to have automatic
search the benefits would be then that
you don't have to learn you don't have
to become an expert of all these
parameters but you can use some kind of
a pneumatic search and for like
researchers this also is beneficial
because you can reduce some kind of
biases if you are inventing a new method
or thinking about a new method then it's
like natural that you are subjective
that you to believe in it and you put
much more effort into one model that is
yours and the others that are the
competitors say kind of ok it's fine so
they give weaker results so it's very
subjective and then in the end you have
ten papers with ten methods and everyone
is saying - is the best this automatic
approach would be like solve this
problem a bit more because it would be
fairer and also the reproduction like of
results would be a bit easier but I
found it I was a bit
I found it kind of curious that this the
Inari known automatic approaches so when
I stumbled upon this I had the feeling
that
nobody uses them so that's why I'm
standing here and advertising them so I
hope you will soon also look onto the
senton maybe I mean okay we don't want
to like reduce our jobs but maybe a bit
more automatisation would be great going
to an example I'm using chaos here which
is just some - new network library and
what you see in here is like very basic
new network as before it has like two
hidden layers and one output layer and
what I want you to look at here is these
these hyper parameters so for example
this number is the 256 units in the
hidden layer would be something you
don't know if this is the right number
so we want to have a choice
you want to try around this now is an
example of one of the libraries I Paris
which is really tied to the specific
machine as to the specific neural
networks library so you can just put it
in here and it's really easy and this
algorithm algorithm is a bit a bit
better than then great search because it
kind of tries to find some combinations
that make sense so I would call it great
search on steroids but it's not yet
Bayesian optimization we're getting to
that point so in this kind of I mean I
cannot really show you the IDI I go with
them because I did not look into the
code but just show you examples of
what's what's possible here so I think
this is a really straightforward
flexible syntax you can just replace
your question marks where you're not
sure by some some choice functions and
then the library is taking takes care of
it
but the problem is that the parameters
are like interdependently run so your
experiments are just run from top to
bottom you could even run them all in
parallel but you don't learn anything in
the East step what I would like to have
is an expert system so a system that
gets like smarter every every experiment
to that to this point there is then a
Bayesian approach so if you maybe you
remember remember this from math or have
seen this like in the other machine
learning methods base you will so we
have a model M and some base some some
basic assumptions
it's the prior and by seeing how like
doing a maximum likelihood approach or
likely you're looking looking at your
likelihood you can compute the posterior
so you can you can see how likely your
model is given the data you have so and
the cool thing is that about this that
is kind of iterative so you you can put
more data and then learn more so and now
how does this apply to our problem
basically we changed some letters and
then thought you make sense right we
want to learn a function which is now
this outer loop function that I showed
you so the function is depend on the
hyper parameters and the data is the
experiments you run so you have some
assumption of your function and again
this likelihood function and then you
can compute your like experiment
expectation so to say your output based
on the data you have run before and you
can when you increase you
your tea when you when you go forward
and produce more experiments then you
your I mean I will show you a picture
right this would be the F that I showed
and the two points here is the Diaz or
the data we already the dashed line is
our goal function that we don't know and
the full stock line is kind of the mean
of our estimation and then what what is
particularly interesting on this and
this Bayesian approach is that you have
some uncertainty measure so you you see
here we know something and here we know
something and we assume if we change it
little on the data then not so much
change so it can be certain that is kind
of near the point where we have that we
have seen before but if we go away from
this point so the x-axis is kind of the
hyper parameter that we can change if we
change the hyper parameter like a lot
then we are uncertain so it could be
anything and this method now does ask
the question at which point at which
hyper parameter do we learn the most or
do we have the highest expectation of
improvement for this then there's like
another function which is called the
acquisition function and we look at the
maximum here too which is kind of what
the algorithm computes to get our new
hyper parameter to try in the next
experiment so in the third experiment
oops yeah I will explain this tool so in
the third experiment we try this point
and then we can see okay we ascertain
here now the headline says it's the
Gaussian process this is kind of the
math that is behind this whole thing so
it was with this slide here the
uncertainty is measured by by Gaussian
distributions this is basically because
it's easy to compute and we can like do
nice
marginalization and computations that
are necessary to do this so that where
the name comes from and the math comes
from I won't go into detail here so much
to not bore you just a new thing to
mention like iterating this again your
your fourth step would be this here to
give you an intuition what this picture
means just if you if I would ask you you
don't see this like acquisition function
and if I would ask you what should I try
next then it makes sense to try here
because you want to maximize this
function in this case and so there is
like this boundary is going up a bit so
our chance to increase our probability
of improvement is the highest whereas if
you look along this line here it's
always kind of below I should have drawn
a dotted edge dashed line here to
visualize it but it doesn't not make
sense so much to try here maybe here it
could be because I mean we can see this
it's modeled but this is the best point
so another library the next library that
implements this algorithm is called spam
and can look it up it's linked in the
end and it it works with configuration
files which is a knife nice thing
because it's not necessarily tied to
neural networks it's you can use it for
every parameter rised model that you
want if you want to so the researcher
that proposed this paper had an example
where he tried this on boiling eggs so
they did kind of their parametres the
cooking time and like how how the water
is before or not or how old the egg is
and all these parameters say they try it
around and just took notes
so it's not even it doesn't even have to
be on the computer that's a major point
here because like there's maybe a lot of
other algorithms that are taking a long
time to compute and you want to really
reduce your amount of experiments you
have you want to do to get a nice result
so yeah as we can see here in the case
of neural networks we have to drop our
parameter which is between 0 & 1 and the
density which can be like 3 values so as
I already explained it can be applied to
anything that has parameters and this
patient approach gives you kind of like
yeah it's uncertain in a certain kind of
range it's optimal so you really reduce
your your time to good result of course
there is no free lunch we have the
problem that this Gaussian process
computation can really take a long time
if you have a lot of parameters because
you have to marginalize everything out
to model this so this acquisition
functions you have seen we in in the
example it was only one-dimensional to a
list illustrate but in in the real world
it's like hyper dimensional and yeah
it's just like you have to think about
it if it's worth trying this process or
if you try around big random search it's
a it's a fair baseline to show you a bit
of data I did not do too many
experiments but um if we this sample
code I showed you when it's when it's
run on on the MS dataset then
we can kind of see that the accuracy
increases and maybe let me tell you the
story of this expert that tries or this
grad student that tries to learn
something how how new networks work and
he can also use this toolbox
mmm to get a better feeling for it
because these two books is a guided
search and then you can make
observations and maybe make like this
these posteriors that are mathematically
can try to explain them for yourself so
if I see here hidden neurons were in the
Indian no tuned case like which was the
beginning where 256 but obviously it
seems like more neurons is good and I
mean this is something everyone that has
some experience with neural network
knows but this is the first step is just
a toy example right and also some
observation would be okay maybe if you
have more neurons then increased dropout
which which is some kind of
regularization is also good because
otherwise your many neurons tend tend to
overfit so the story line here is that
these are things you can explain and
maybe you can even with these libraries
you can even learn things you didn't
know before this is something in you
could have known but there may be other
things when you make this such larger
then you see things that you didn't know
before that's I think a very nice
property so as a conclusion a bit fast
you should try patient optimization on
your next experiment on your next
project if you have something that is
similar to it so for example neural
networks or something that is really
computationally expensive and has a lot
of happen hyper parameters and get the
papers from Jasper snook and Dykstra
show that they
can really they did it on like less toy
examples than me they did it on large
neural networks with competitive results
on the image net competition competition
for example and they could tuned the
model to better than expert so they
could kind of win the competition with
it and of course hyper up then spam and
were just two examples but out of the
Python world there's another Python
library down that I discovered them
which is trying to unify these
approaches so there's a third five
algorithm that is working well which is
called as Mac and you can find all of
them conclude tie together here and of
course as I said before
unfortunately there's no such thing as a
free lunch but I think this could still
be beneficial so thanks for your
attention
so are there any questions so the
question was how did I defend the
acquisition function let us
oops something that's a good question
because I mean this is kind of something
you have to decide so now we had this no
freelance think it's this kind of a
hyper parameter yeah this is for example
would be I did not show the math you
have to look into the papers to see the
math actually to see the actual math but
is some kind of marginalization your
expected improvement it's kind of
defined mathematically I can show you if
you want later so they just say how much
chance have I got here to improve to the
thing that I have before if I add a
neuron yeah so this acquisition function
then gives me at this point and this is
basically a set of hyper parameters and
then I run a whole neural network
process so then I for example it says
you should use so on so many neurons and
this and this learning rate and then I
put this into my inner loop that I
showed before so I he said the hyper
meters I'm talking about and this inner
loop is then running and then I get a
new result and I can update my my
function that I'm was expecting his OID
update is then after then the whole new
network trained one time for example for
a couple of hours then I get a new data
point
yes
so the question was if that's a
chicken-and-egg problem because Gaussian
processes have a lot of parameters so I
think to think it's a bit more abstract
so the tendency is there I also ask
myself that when I was looking here but
I think you can yeah basically get a bit
more away from it and to do whole
parameters of the Gaussian processes are
integrated out so this is the thing that
is very expensive of course we have to
define a prior or something some pre
assumptions but yeah that's choice you
make to make the one of the authors of
this of this method said this would be
then this ground assumption in instead
of having lots of different parameters
so the question was if this method would
help in like that you don't run an
experiment that's then really like
messed up if you rephrase it like this
and I think you still have to go into
some way of like accepting that your
experiment goes in the wrong direction
sometimes to learn new things about the
parameters for example if you imagine
this grad student shirts search like
you're trying around then you try
something you tried the boundaries and
you want to see how it behaves there and
then you can but what you can do then is
like see okay this really goes away and
then you can stop so the experiment is
not so expensive in this case more
expensive and more interesting it's in
the areas where it's the
fine differences yes syndrich wrong
dimension so this so dislike so the
question was what is to drop out 1.0
mean that isn't that like everything is
dropped I think it could be right that's
I have to look into that that is so
question were all alike explanation was
that then the initialization weights
would be used I am not sure what happens
then
yeah sure I mean so these are all the
same like very very similar results
because I have a really easy problem
here and also I mean this is just to
kind of see if it works or not so it's
kind of toy very toy example and but as
you pointed out this if we have to look
into this
to about thing Thanks more questions
question was if this what it is to do
with Python if this is template
variables and where the outer loop is so
you're right it's it's like outside of
this and the hyper us library then
transformed this code transforms this
code into actual Python in it you can it
prints it when it starts running so it's
basically replaced and then putting in
the different options step by step yeah
you can't run it without high press
anymore and that's what I meant by at
this point I don't know I don't know if
I explained it strongly tied to the
model so I mean also the names are
really right cameras hyper us so it's a
decision you make I think I also thought
about that and I think it's like thing
about the library specificity hmm maybe
maybe you could still parameter
yourself and then put your template
variable somewhere else if you want that
there would be ugly as well what
questions okay yeah